all right okay hi everyone
so today there was actually a Miss
mix-up where we kind of mixed up the
stream keys and so I have actually been
building a calculator for the last hour
and it wasn't live so yeah sorry about
that
it's an hour late but I'm still gonna
build the calculator if you don't know
me my name is Gwen
I run a channel called Faraday Academy
here on YouTube and today free code camp
has nicely let me continue my series of
streaming all of the free code camp
projects but built in view Jas and you
can find the link to the repo for all
the projects it's right in the
description below specifically today I'm
building the calculator project and so
let me just give you the breakdown real
quick so the calculator is of course one
of the front end projects on a free code
camp site and I'm gonna be building it
with view this library called math Jas
which basically helps with 12
mathematical operations in JavaScript it
can give you a safer evaluation function
so you don't have to use eval in
JavaScript and I checked the source code
it doesn't use eval under the hood which
is good and it also helps you with
rounding errors using different kind of
types of numbers like big num stuff like
that
bootstrap view same thing I used last
week when I was building the drum
machine just for a little bit of styling
it's a lightweight styling library and
then here is not really a mock-up but
this is actually a screenshot of the
calculator that I built for the free
code camp curriculum five years ago and
so I'm pretty much following the same
pattern except I'm making
the buttons look more digital and modern
but you know it's almost the same thing
so by the way here's my code pen and
this is the calculator I built back in
2015 so let me just see real quick make
sure I can see the chat yeah so this is
a calculator and built way back then and
I was checking you know for so long I
didn't want to look at this code I just
didn't want to see it it's like oh no
what did I write back then but basically
I'm using jQuery and where is it where
is it I am using yeah I'm using
JavaScript eval function which if you
read mdn or any of the other
documentation sites for JavaScript you
know they'll all say don't use don't
ever use eval because it's not safe so
I'm not gonna be using that today I was
just trying to I guess look at what I
did back then but yeah I mean only so
many ways to do a calculator now since
the stream accidentally started an hour
ago
I'm kind of starting in the middle but
not really because basically the only
thing that I've done so far are the only
things that I've done are I started the
view app so view create started a new
view app I installed
bootstrap view which I set up here where
is it in my main j/s I have to of course
import the library use view use to set
up the plug-in so I can use all of the
components with view and then import the
styling so I imported bootstrap and
bootstrap view so that was what I did
for setup in my app file I added a
container in a row and a column just to
Center the calculator on the page and
then in the actual calculator it was
kind of weird to start in the middle but
I'm gonna I'm redoing all of the
JavaScript here so
let's start from scratch in the actual
calculator JavaScript so but yeah so the
buttons are actually inside of a card a
bootstrap card and I have the output
screen and these button this container
with all these rows that contains the
buttons and so last week with the drum
machine that I built in view I use divs
to kind of make the buttons look like
this as square but someone pointed out
to me that actually for accessibility
reasons I should be using you know
actual HTML buttons and not just divs so
I changed that today and for the
calculator I'm using actual buttons so I
guess for screen readers and stuff it'll
be easier much much better for
navigation alright so that's pretty much
it and then for styling I just have some
styles pretty basic setting like height
and width of the width of the card
height and width of the buttons so they
all look nice and square bootstrap and
kind of made that easy and then I'm also
using bootstraps colors
you're very warning colors for these
orange buttons if you don't know I mean
I'm sure so many calculator examples are
built like this but let me open the Mac
calculator oh it popped up on the screen
so the Mac calculator looks kind of like
this and it's pretty much the same so
orange operations and then they have you
know dark darker colors here so kind of
mimicking that a little bit I'll
probably update the styling a little bit
later but for right now I'm just gonna
start adding in the view j/s JavaScript
so yeah hopefully that's not too
confusing to start with it's not really
starting in the middle because it's
mostly just styling that's been done and
now for the JavaScript I'm gonna have to
add basically I'm going to have separate
operators let me pull up the calculator
one more time so I think this calculator
does it so let me do just yeah and so
you can see the first operand right 54 I
typed in and then I hit the operator
which stays highlighted and then I start
typing in a second operand which comes
up on the screen and then I can hit
equals and it will evaluate the
operation the expression so I can yeah
so I'm gonna use the same basic method
here and I'm gonna do store these
variables in data so let's see hi Quincy
thank you
yeah let's see I have operand so I have
operand or I'll call this first first
operand and second operand unless
someone has a better idea and this is
going to be a string because it's easy
to append numbers onto a string I think
that will be the easiest way to do this
and then I need to store the second
operand separately as a string and then
I also need to store the operator which
will also be a string and then
basically yeah basically I'm gonna be
displaying the first operand unless the
second operand value is not null then
I'll be displaying that one and then
when I run the evaluation or when I hit
equals that will evaluate the expression
into the first operand value and then
that will be displaying again on the
screen and it will wipe out the second
operand value if that makes sense so let
me try that so I shouldn't need a
separate display value so let's see
methods and actually I don't actually
think I'll need like different methods
for add subtract and that sort of thing
because this math Jas library has kind
of a cheat a cheat method so yeah if you
can see this math dot evaluates where I
can just pass in an expression so I'm
gonna make my own multiple operators I
don't think so because so when I use
this calculator I mean not this whole
left-hand side but when I use the basic
calculator seven times nine and then it
if I hit another one it evaluates
already so I don't actually need
multiple operators because now in fact
if I have - it just ran the evaluation
and now I can subtract and then if I hit
another operator it runs the evaluation
and so on so yeah so I don't think I do
Oh the order of operations yeah so maybe
maybe that's version two then if I want
to have order of operations capability
so you can type in multiple things or a
whole expression or something maybe
maybe that'll come later so let me start
off this way then and plus if I have all
of these stored separately
I guess I guess if I wanted if I wanted
to do that that way I could make an
expression string and then just append
everything into one string and then
evaluate the whole thing yeah let's see
how this works let me do an eval make my
own eval function and so what do I want
to do oh yeah let me import the math Jas
library oh no first
okay so I have eval let me set up all
the methods first so I have eval
I also need an append number which isn't
just number because it can also be a dot
so I can make floats and stuff so append
character I guess should I call it that
and this is actually the first method I
want to set up and what this will do
will take the operand right now I'm just
going to work on the first operand and
then I'll set up the logic to handle the
second one too so this will take this
top first operand plus equals whatever
character I pass in and then for a
penned character here I can call that
method via and on click so let's see
yeah I highlighted all the right things
so okay and now escape insert and now I
can just add a click to all of these
buttons and it will be append operand no
no no what did I call it a pen character
pen character and then I have to pass in
the character which is different for
each one of these so I won't even put a
placeholder there all right and here I'm
gonna pass in one
whoops and here's two here is three so
used to the shortcuts on a mechanical
keyboard and use this default just a
plain keyboard for live streaming so
it's a little bit different okay so the
seven eight nine oh wait I do want a pen
character on these other ones too okay
I'll fix that in a second so here is 0.4
the for the operators I don't want a pen
character so I'm gonna change that oh it
doesn't like that I'm passing in a dot
about that has to be in a string okay
all right so
oh yeah and then I need to display it in
the screen here so like I said right now
I'm just working with the first upper
end so that's all I'm gonna display for
right now so first operand cool all
right so let me take a little pause and
fix the styling inside of here so let me
re I guess realign this with flexbox let
me look for bootstraps flexbox
characters
okay so flexbox options let's see
[Music]
there's ability I don't think I'm in the
right thing let me look again
Oh bootstrap utility classes here they
are
so oh yeah because these come from the
regular bootstrap library which I also
had to import so border utilities flex
utilities so it's taking me to the
actual bootstrap documentation and flex
display flex okay and I think let's see
oh this isn't Darrell so this doesn't
have display flex by default so let me
do display flex here and
oh yeah cuz I have to put stuff in there
and then I want to do a line item Center
and then give it some padding so let me
do padding first so padding of just on
all sides of two which I think is
something like eight pixels okay so that
will bring it out from the left side and
now I want to Center it vertically which
should be aligned items so aligned items
so I'll do a line items Center
so after Flex a line items Center okay
cool
that looks better I could make the font
a little bit bigger but I think that's
okay yeah I will have to show more than
the first operand but I'm just setting
up the first operand so I could get a
pending working okay but now okay so
with the dot I need to handle that
special so if someone's trying to pass
in a dot they should only be able to do
that one time so let me also it's kind
of annoying not having a clear button I
might just add that and then figure out
how to fit that in the calculator after
let me put that after the card oh no
let me just add another row then with
just a Clear button for now and then
I'll rearrange the buttons later so let
me add this row at the top and because
this will be an easy method to just do
so clear and
well this BAC or just see ya
alright so because as I'm working it's
gonna be just convenient to have a clear
option so clear and for right now just
for the first operand so I'm just gonna
set that to an empty string okay so if I
have this here alright so that clears
the value and it does look kind of weird
being like on the lonely space up top I
could make this display:block so the
button goes all the way across oh yeah
but it it gives it a width of a hundred
percent but the width is already set so
let me inspect this rules yeah because I
set the width in a scoped style so I
could overwrite that so BTN block so
since this is s CSS I'll just nest a
style in here so and dot BTN block and
I'll do with 100% okay so now the Clear
button and let me also make that orange
real quick so what we do variant variant
which will be warning
alright okay that doesn't look too bad
let me get rid of that okay so now I
have a clear and oh yeah for the periods
I need to have some logic around when
and how you can use a period you can
only use one decimal point in a number
so I have to search for that so let's
see in a pen character I need to check
so if this dot char is a period then I
have to do basically let me just nest an
if statement so if this dot first
operand dot contains so if it already
contains a period then I'm gonna do this
dot I'm basically going to do the same
thing as here so I'll append it only if
it oh if it doesn't contain it so I need
to negate this actually so if this stuff
first operand contains a period if it
doesn't contain a period already then
append the period otherwise do nothing I
don't want to give them a warning or
anything so let's see if that works so
three point eight point oh it's still
doing it
so let's see okay so there's no problems
let's see first operand if it doesn't
contain a period so I can maybe I'll do
a debugger
sometimes when I'm live-streaming my my
debugger doesn't work too well but let's
see so if this da
Oh dis da charm n okay so yeah it's the
cuz I want to check against the char
that I'm passing in so let's see if this
works now okay well now it doesn't let
you ever put a period in so if this da
char equals period so let's just see if
it hits it hits the log statement here
let's do
let me go to console and this smaller oh
wait does have oh this stop first
operand that contains it's not a
function okay so I think that's my issue
and I thought there was let's see
JavaScript contains
okay so there's oh is it includes I
think it's includes maybe I'm thinking
of something else
so includes I think that's what that's
the method that I want all right let's
see point
so that's not working
well it's getting here anyway so I need
to find out what this is so let me send
a debugger here too many too many what
too many period yeah I know I should
only have one in there
so let me do one period now it should
pull up that method okay so it's that
first operand includes so I should be
able to see wait
my first operand is one and then I
should be able to see let me step over
step over yeah chart is that so this
expression I guess it shouldn't be
evaluating to true if not
let me see let me get rid of this
statement and just log it out so console
dot log and I think maybe my logic is
backwards here it adds a period if there
is already any period at all
it's skipped you need to put the outer a
pen oh yeah that's right that's right so
I need to wrap this and else all right
thanks
all right so now it's still doing it why
is it adding to did I add it in else if
so if the character is a period I'm
wondering if this method is getting
called twice because now I'm so I'm
doing okay so inside of a pen character
I call a pen character if the character
is a period then it should just run this
if statement I don't I don't think it's
a misplaced else though because it
should only be running this if statement
if the characters are period and then
inside of that I run another if
statement if it already includes that
then don't run it basically so this else
should be working
that's weird if else that's the right
JavaScript syntax so if char is period
then why is it running the second one -
hmm okay so
yeah I'm not sure why I don't have any
other place where I'm appending so let
me just log out I guess this one I'd
have to do just a string to
differentiate it and then here no I
don't think so though because this is
only checking if it already includes a
period so I don't want to append it
because then I would be doing the same
thing in the if and the else statement
in here which I don't want to do oh let
me see okay so let me clear that clear
this okay so it's logging out that and
now if I do period
yeah now it works okay I think I just
needed to refresh it somehow yeah okay
that was weird
all right so that's fine all right so
now I have the just the first operand
pending so now if I hit an operation an
operator I need to store these operators
in some kind of operator or any yeah I
need to store them in operator so now I
need to make here let's see yeah so the
I think that's it
no that's good okay so I'll do at click
and when I click I want to just straight
update the operator variable so operator
will equal whatever operators inside of
this button so for the first one it's
gonna be a plus sign and let me put
these on more lines okay so the first
time for the plus sign I set the
operator equal to plus for this I set
the operator equal to minus and then
which one is this oh four times I can
set the operator equal to the star
symbol and for define I'll set it equal
to divide okay I think that's right and
then equals is gonna have its own I'll
just go ahead and change equals to eval
even though I haven't set up that
function yet okay so I think all of the
functions are correct now let me look in
the view dev tools okay
so in view dev tools I'll look at but oh
yeah I want to look at my calculator
component so inside app calculator and
then when I click on these it's not
doing anything okay do I have an error
let me refresh
okay so
when I click oh that was weird
when I started clicking on the operands
it updated the operator - huh I wonder
why it's doing that
because I'm clicking on these buttons
but when I click on the minus sign the
operator still says plus until I hit
another button here and now it says - I
think that's just a matter of refreshing
in the view dev tools so let me hit
times and then refresh yeah so that's
just a refreshing problem in the B dev
tools okay so let me see if they let me
zoom in yet no they don't
okay ba dev tools still doesn't let me
zoom in oh well okay so the operator is
getting saved so now if the operator
exists yeah I know sorry Tom I can't
zoom in unless maybe I zoomed in via
this does that I don't know waiting for
the screen to update I think I probably
have like a 10 second leg I think right
now so waiting waiting waiting I don't
know that zoom doesn't work oh well all
right so let's see maybe light mode no I
think just in Firefox in general it
doesn't work right now
I cause I switched I didn't I switched
to dark mode not that long ago I think
it was on one of my live streams where
someone suggested me to use dark mode
yeah chrome dev tools I should set up
from my chrome doesn't have any
extensions right now I just use it for
UI testing that's it so I could set that
up and you know just use Chrome maybe
I'll have that for next time okay
so what is it okay so I have the first
operand I have the operator and now if
the operator exists actually I want to
make a function for the operator because
if there's no first operand I don't want
to set the operator yet but I'll worry
about that in a minute
that'll just be a known bug so the
second operand if the if the operator
exists I want to start working on the
second operand so what I'm gonna have to
do in here
is set the current operator so Const
current operator equals let's say this
dot
I need to check so if this dot operator
exists then the current upper operand Oh
current operand operand if this operator
exists meaning if they've already hit
like plus or minus or something then I
want the current operand to be the
second one otherwise I want it to be the
first one okay and I'm gonna put this on
two lines so it's easier to see and I
thought maybe that's just in Python I
thought I could alright so I can still
put it on two lines but I'll just do it
here instead so do the parentheses here
yeah that works right so if the operator
has already been typed in then the
current operand will be the second one
otherwise the first one and so now I
need to and I think I can just mutate
state from here and actually let me do
let here not Const so I think now
because this should be point oh no it's
a string value so
so first operand so I wonder if this is
going to be is it's not a pointer so I
wonder what is the best way to update
this then and to set you know if the
operator exists it should operate it
should be the second one otherwise the
first one and I kind of don't want an if
statement inside each one of these so
yeah I'm not sure definitely in the
output screen though I definitely want
if the second one exists if the second
one exists I want to display it
otherwise the first one
so if second one's false it'll display
the first one so that was now let me
think about the logic here so I want to
do I need to pick the the current one
set current opera into a string and then
yeah that will work
that will work actually that's a good
idea okay so I'll set it to a string so
let me do yeah just a string and then
yeah and then here I'll do this so I'll
do this current operand Thanks that's
that's a good idea and then I want the
same logic in the else statement so
there okay and that will be the same as
like this dot second operand or this top
first operand are these spelled
correctly
yeah current operand just checking
spelling here okay so that should work
so let me see if that works actually so
let me do 25 plus sweet that's good
let me see if they're saving in the
right places just to double-check and
calculator yeah I have them all saving
in the right places so then technically
in eval I could just do let's see I
could do well let me import the function
that I want the math function so I want
to import evaluate from math so yeah
math jeaious so up here at the top of
the script tag I can do import evaluate
from math j/s and now in eval I can just
use you've got evaluate and then I need
to pass in a string so I'll just add
these strings together concatenate them
so first I'm gonna be first operand oh
it has to be this so
this actually because I'm using this
three times let me pull them off of this
so Const first operand second operand
and operator equals this and then I'm
gonna concatenate them with just make
one big string so first operator first
operand plus operator plus second
operand yeah
okay so evaluate now I have to store
this somewhere so this is the logic so
I'm gonna have to do this dot first
operand equals the result of the
evaluation and then I'm going to set the
second one to be an empty string again
and oops and then the operator oh wait
the operator to also be an empty string
so I'm going to reset those two and set
the result to first operand yeah let's
see
let me do that alright so twelve plus
three equals fifteen sweet and now if I
do it again I should be able to oh no oh
no no 18 21 no it's adding every time
it's not resetting the operator why not
let's see
the operator is blank here so mmm that's
weird
water
all right mm-hmm so the operator is
blank in the dev tools we need to give a
hard refresh and see if it's just buggy
+6 okay
and now if I try it okay yeah now I can
append and now -6 nope
yeah so there's some things going on
here and now clear doesn't work maybe
I've a error no errors anywhere hmm
let's see 23 plus 3 equals 26 okay
that's good
let's do plus 5 that's good equals 31
that's all good
let's do minus 3 equals 28 okay
everything's good so far
now let me add an appended number know
what happens in my dev tools refresh
31:34 okay the operator is blank it's an
empty string I keep refreshing it's an
empty string the second operators blank
first operators 41 so it should append
but instead it's adding 300 I think I
know why okay so this is evaluating and
becomes a number value so I think
JavaScript okay so I think because the
result of evaluate is a number and not a
string so then in Java scripts mind I'm
I am so I have 40 for the number and
then I'm adding 3 the string so it
thinks I want to add 3 the number so it
parses it as a number and adds it of
course if I add
period okay yeah and now I don't have
the includes function cuz now first
operand is a number so I need to change
this to string basically yeah
so parse int oh yeah so it would be two
string I think at the end so two string
and I think that's what I have to do I
don't think I have an STR function like
in Python so let's see if this works
yeah that's that's one thing about types
in JavaScript let's see so 12 plus 3
equals 15 now if I do yep okay minus 5
equals ah okay cool so that all works as
intended that wasn't didn't take as long
as I thought I would yeah and then
divided by 9 equals oh yeah so now the
rounding in JavaScript because I think
if I do let me do 10 10 divided by 4
which should be 2.5 it is 2.5 ok so no
problem there I think there are some
numbers where it doesn't it doesn't
round where there are some numbers where
it doesn't round quite right maybe the
math library is taking care of that for
me so yeah so is there anything else I
should do I should probably do some
cleanup like when I do plus like when I
hit one of these symbols and its current
I need to set the class also I don't
like that again
rid of the border when I hover so let me
fix some of that some of the styling
stuff so on the button let me do and
hover because I'm using sass and so when
I hover over the button class I want
there to be no change in the border so
border one pixel solid I think oh yeah
and then I have to set I do need to set
the color because for the dark colors it
defaults to white and blue strap so I
have to set black cool that looks better
and now let me see what class it's
adding to make the color darker because
then I could set active that as the
active operator I guess so let's see
hover so let me set the hover state on
plus and
what styles is it good having me oh yeah
it just it's just basically darkening
the color and I think it's doing it in
sass so I don't know exactly the
percentage that it's actually making it
darker let's see yeah I'm just gonna
come up with a percentage because sass
gives me those color classes so I can do
and hover so when I hover over a button
I'm gonna set my own background color is
but then I should set a variable here I
guess so let's see what's the regular
color oh the regular color without being
hovered over is orange so let me set
these variables and sass and I don't
know if I can do these inside components
I guess I can cuz I'm just writing
regular sass so let me set a variable
called orange and
orange is that color and then oh did it
not like that oh because I didn't set
the background color okay so now I can
do dollar sign orange yeah and a oh wait
I'm hovering over all these that's not
what I want
okay so button okay let me do the other
variable so let me inspect this and get
that gray color so here's the gray
background for the other buttons and I'm
gonna put that in a variable too so I'm
gonna call this dark gray and there we
go and now so the button now I'm gonna
have to set the background color of the
buttons to be default of dark gray and
then if it's BTN warning class then I
want to set it set the background color
as orange okay
so now it should be over writing those
colors and this will let me oops and
this will let me do hover hover classes
now so now I can do darken use the sass
method darken and what was the other
what do I owe ya I pass in the color for
so dark gray and I think there is a way
to access the relative color here but I
can't remember how to do it so let's do
darken it by 10% and if it's a warning
one then we can oh yeah so basically be
doing the same thing
get rid of the border and then I'll do
orange here it might be a little bit
more than it was okay and now so this is
on hover and now I want that same well I
probably don't need 10% we just changed
this to 8% it's a little bit extreme
and now I want that same thing basically
if the button is active so if I clicked
on one of these ones one of these four
then I want it to stay active I guess so
let's see
let me do so I need some kind of special
operator class here a class on the
operator buttons because clear you know
has warning but I don't want it to stay
active so I need like some kind of I
don't know I'll do the class of operator
here and
[Music]
okay so let me paste that paste that and
then okay so all the operators have a
class of operator now maybe I didn't
arrange this sass the best way because
this dark in color I also want if if so
yeah this is more code I guess then it
should be I might look up a sass
shortcut for this so anyway if it has
the class operator as well as button
then I want to also change the
background color to be darker background
color and I want it to darken so oh wait
oh yeah I only need this operator class
and button warning because I don't
actually want it in the other one so
yeah that will work because I only ever
want it for dark orange of course I
could save dark orange in a variable -
oh wait only if it's active though
active okay so maybe I'll have the class
called active operator and then in my
class I'll make this a dynamic class and
basically only set that class equal to
so let me make an array here or let's
see an object
yeah I'll make an object and I'll give
it the class active - operator oh wait
this will have to be in quotes because
it's hyphenated only if I'll give it the
class active operator only if the
operator variable and this is where
pretty earth is nice because I haven't
set up correctly on save it just formats
on my code for me you don't have to do
any of this okay so if the operator is
the forward slash then I want this
button to be set as active operator so
let's see yeah now it's active cool so I
have to set this up for all of them now
basically so and is this that different
no I just have to update this so I'm
just gonna copy this whole thing
actually paste paste
paste and okay let me get rid of that oh
yeah get rid of this button and okay so
now I have all of those and now I just
need to update this because I pasted it
in so this is multiplied and this one is
minus and this one is add okay well hmm
oh it's the same thing in these I forgot
about that
oh well so that one's add this one
active operator is oh wait why do I have
B call around that one and none of the
other ones I should get rid of that I
will in one second let me finish doing
this I was wondering why it was a
different number of tabs inward okay so
do that and now let me get rid of this
column here so so the wrong button okay
so 32 plus yep and now it's active so
it's a little bit darker plus 6 equals
yeah and now it goes away after that so
now if I do - it stays highlighted - 52
equals negative 14 okay there are other
things I could do like you know instead
of having this clear the whole way
across and see if after
twelve already instead of having this
clear the whole way across
I could put other buttons like that a
sign button is that even on the math
calculator yeah changes the sign so if I
have an eight it continues the sign to
negative eight positive eight
I can change it into a percentage let's
see
cool
yeah I think it turned out pretty well
there are some known bugs like you can
hit an operator before anything is in
there so I should make an operator class
really equals oh so okay so it would be
zero so oh yeah that's what I should do
actually I shouldn't change the operator
at all what I should do is if there's no
second operator no first operator then
can I do this yeah I can stack oars it
should be zero
yeah so it's zero now cool so it would
be zero minus six equals negative six
yeah that makes sense actually change
the colors on click instead of hover I
do need some kind of hover like hover
state but now if I click on it it stays
in that state so I know that it's active
basically okay until I hit the equals
sign now when I so when I have like
let's say I have plus six and then I do
- I should it should evaluate if I try
to hit a second operator it should
evaluate
you click a number after an equal sign
it starts calculating a new math problem
if you click a number after the equals
sign I'm not sure so after the equals
sign so if I hit equals and then another
number I mean it kind of I guess you
start calculating you mean you can
somehow make a math expression here this
calculator isn't isn't up there yet so
you calculate one problem and instantly
start a new problem isn't it doing that
though maybe I'm confused at what you're
saying but like right now now that I hit
equals I start a new problem equals and
then the new problem because it's reset
to the state it was at the beginning
except the first operand equals this
number windows calculator so let me
actually so when I hit a second operator
right now it doesn't work as intended so
when I hit if I do plus three now if I
had a second operator and needs to run
the eval function before and then store
the second operator so how am I going to
do that I think this is the last thing
I'm gonna do in this stream because I
was streaming for a whole hour before it
went live so I talked about a lot of
stuff thinking that just I was like man
the chats really quiet all right so
let's say oh yeah so this operator
operator equals I need to make a method
so I need to make some kind of method
here called like update operator
and okay update operator and then oh
yeah I'll have to pass it in here so
operator which doesn't overwrite I mean
this is kind of confusing maybe I'll
call it oops I'll call it Opie here
because there is a vista operator which
is on my component state here Oh num
plus num yeah I don't I'm not gonna have
it I don't have time in this stream to
do like a whole expression I'm just
gonna keep it the way it is for right
now but if you want to make a PR to the
repo and fix the code you are more than
welcome to so pass in the operator and I
will set this dot operator equal to the
operator that I pass in so now let me
copy this method and now I'm gonna
change it here so update operator the
method and then do the same thing for
all of these really so alright update
operator yeah for - update operator
that'll give me more control over what I
do when I update it
Update operator alright so now I've
updated let me just make sure that's
working wait yeah I did that right okay
I forgot what I did for a second so now
that I have update operator so now
inside of update operator I can check
and say if this dot operator so if
there's already an operator set then I
can run this dot eval yeah call this
eval evaluate the expression and inside
of this eval it's going to clear the
second up operand and the operator
so then after eval because they've
already typed in a second operator I
want to go ahead and save that after but
if there is no current operator anyways
I want to save the operator so I think
this will work
yeah I haven't pushed the code yet I
will in just a second let me do 23 plus
five and now instead of hitting equals
I'm gonna hit - cool
so it ran the operation and now it's
stored the second operator so now I can
have another second operand so five
times six plus three and you get the
idea okay
okay so it's running evaluations as I'm
going I think that's pretty good there
can be some improvements but I think
overall it turned out pretty well what
do you think yeah I'm gonna do a commit
so is there any more cleanup I need to
do
any useless I can do small cleanup like
that and I think I'm not using
border-box
that style one style box-sizing yeah you
see if it still works yeah
so I think that's the last thing to
clean up maybe we'll find more stuff
later but overall I think it's pretty
good alright so let me stop the dev
server then thanks does anyone have any
questions comments statements you want
to make about this calculator or view or
anything let me go up a directory
because the git repo contains all of
these folders so might get free code
camp projects view do git status and I
added the calculator app I already have
a get ignore file that's good so I'm
gonna do git add just add everything get
commit - M code from live stream thanks
thanks Kumar code from live stream on I
can't believe it took me an hour to
realize that my app said I was live but
it wasn't actually going to the free
code camp stream so sorry about that
get commits - M code from live stream on
July 10th July 10th for me anyway
get push
now let me see if it updated oops if it
updated yeah I think overall this yeah
so and I have the calculator app code
inside of here I think overall this one
turned out much much better than my old
one if you want to see my old code I'll
post it in the chat here you can take a
look and what I was doing back in 2015
just eval all the things basically in
jQuery so yeah definitely come a long
way in development I think I was trying
to do some object thing but I couldn't
get it to work or something happened I
don't remember now but yeah that's my
old calculator and the new calculator
much better cleaner not not great
stylings not great but bootstrap helped
a lot so yeah thanks for joining the
stream today Oh what is the theme Oh
real quick let me go to the theme this
is a plugin that someone suggested to me
during a stream actually so where is it
where is it it's pale pale night theme
it's this theme and I thought it was
kind of weird like a lot of purple at
first but it's it's growing on me
I think I'm gonna keep it for a while so
yeah it's a great theme was used VIU's
code to highlight that code block when
you wanted to change indentation oh I
use vim so envious code I use vim
where's Finn key bindings basically so
if I'm in like if I'm on this line I can
press shift V and it highlights the
whole line if I want to highlight part
of a line then I do V and then I can W
over or B for back highlight different
things V and then I can go up or down
with J and K I think
down many lines at a time yeah that was
great
I recommend it and it makes it even
better when you're using it in BS code
because you get all of the vs code
shortcuts and then you get the vim
shortcuts too and if you use vim enough
you know copy pasting and vim can be a
real pain going from file to file but in
vs code I think it makes it a nice
development experience to use film
inside vs code so yeah I look I have
enjoyed it a lot especially using a
mechanical keyboard where I can kind of
set set up my keys how I want and then
set some macros like multiple keystrokes
saved into one key where I just press
one key and it does a bunch of things
which is fun so yeah thanks so much for
the stream you should check it out if
you have any questions or something
leave them in the comments below and
feel free to reach out to me I also have
my youtube channel Faraday Academy you
should check it out I do lots of view
and Python content over on there and I
hope you all have a great day
take care